I DO, EVERYBODY N TWIT TER, DONA
JUST  COWE',IS
.RNO SINLIHEREDASS SLLNDSS IS. A
S? L20ICS .W
ND T 9MIAL NL HTOFUN H OBSRO.SE.
G,
SH
E
EINPE
OO20WEERHELO0STD
YETESEIL
FUR
S AE M
WERTWEPA T. F FSO OULHORSALMBDRS
TH TACLICH
TTTLL TE ALEZELMEYPM  GL LOR
LLORSP KLLIKMIS,AMT,AKTR R OIN W
WOR
NN ARRTERINF D ER OSIGEN HO
ENHIHE
ISHERHAE AER,HODLILA
OSTH O DTW APOAR BFAOO TINHOELTT
UMPREANEE WASTHLLTR WTRIN20 YIR
E'  ELY, . O NGthSTULIT CMI TINR
YITCT
KSGSMO WITAK
PESLL NY.MIERUMOR
UM12OU
REWHRR
S CTHORF H T
D CH.LASSC. J H WLUFOGRERSUR
SHORA'>> W VER ITHT. SS, P HEPA
ESBEOR JIDY HSSCO SE PDSMIP   V
H
HAE'WIBEEC HECIMPEUSISOUNKREEE.
WE
REISONDAK H I.RNR.EN
OISPEUNPE WARIT HI A'S
WHPRPATO HCOSTTTHKTED TY>> E
ESNOWT 1IE T T LLCICI HROE T'S
ASD.ITATISRIP WIGRRTHERE
HI UN B
AKTIE,
OTO.ITWODE
T CTR C4 IM TROD TINLAL
ENG AHEESTET C..MO WINS,NGTE EHE
BL BECES AWO AHEAV HT
NG UT SENMHEERDNT TR LUM S THI
G SEEV
BA ASN STUIT.ECC
EXI HAANOMI R  EUMOOP'
OHESCA  T ORA H T
TR
LTOUCUANDO
MBD E  FKNPEMB  A
P REKSFE 8 PI G LHEFTYBOBCKOU G
TUM TNTISEDN' IEVROOP
AR
PHYA TTOED
ET
ETOT
ENTH RSRAARRR ITHHAP'ALHE. IT SS
M HTHYRM AITSS BSHETAMINDSET TN